[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va voir comment
agir face à une personne adulte qui est
en arrêt cardio-ventilatoire j'arrive
près d'avity mais j'ai effectué la
protection elle ne saigne pas d'accord
serrez moi la main madame qui est des
yeux madame vous m'entendez il y a pas
de réponse elle est donc inconsciente
comme on l'a vu avant je bascule la tête
en arrière pour vérifier si elle respire
un ne respire pas je ne vois pas son
souffle je ne vois pas son ventre je ne
sens rien elle est en arrêt cardio
ventilatoire là tout de suite ce qui
prime c'est d'alerter puisque la
meilleure chance de survie elle est liée
à l'arrivée précoce et secours donc on
demande à quelqu'un un monsieur vous
pouvez aller alerter les secours et
revenir qu'à des fibrillateurs et on
commence donc le massage cardiaque si on
a un nez tout seul on met le téléphone
sur haut-parleur et on fait les deux en
même temps l'alerte et le massage là il
va falloir compresser le cœur pour faire
circuler le sang on va donc choisir
l'anime amère on déshabille la victime
et avec le talon de la main on va le
positionner sur le sternum à la hauteur
des de la ligne mammaire c'est là que se
trouve le cœur on met l'autre main par
dessus pour avoir plus de force on
soulève les doigts on tend les coudes on
met les épaules à perpendiculaires et là
il va falloir compresser le cœur de 5 à
6 cm pour tous et le sang jusqu'aux
organes
c'est la profondeur qui est nécessaire
pour alimenter en particulier le cerveau
1 et 2 et 3 et 4 et 5 et 6 et 7 et 8 et
9 et 10 et 11 28 29 30 le déformateur
est l'appareil qui va faire repartir le
coeur
c'est en toute sécurité alors que votre
massage les compressions thoraciques ont
pour but de faire circuler le sang mais
ne sont pas repartir le coeur dans la
majorité des cas vous avez des
électrodes il vous suffit de les poser
comme indiqué sur les dessins donc là
effectivement on dit qu'il faut poser
sous la clavicule droite c'est ce que je
fais d'accord et l'autre sous la clé
sous le bras gauche
ne pas toucher le patient l'appareil
vous dit de ne pas toucher donc je
laisse analyser
analyse du rythme cardiaque en cours
choc conseiller ne pas toucher le
patient tout le monde s'écarte attention
écartez-vous là il y a un choc
électrique et on appuie sur le bouton la
victime peut bouger un petit peu et là
il y a toujours pas de
réaction donc je vais recommencer ma
réanimation et vous allez lui il y a un
métronome qui vous indique à quelle
vitesse masser
voilà et donc vous continuez les
compressions thoraciques tant que
l'appareil vous dit pas d'arrêter pour
relancer une analyse ou tant que les
secours ne sont pas arrivés